everybody in this room is making between
$1 million per year and $12 million per
year and we just talked for the last 60
Minutes on how to scale their business
enjoy all right so you got neuropathy um
you're doing 5 million year what's the
model uh done for you scheduling okay Le
okay is it local neuropathy stuff yeah
so diabetic dinners and all that jazz
dinners and yeah familiar with the model
okay um so then what's the what's the
what's the big play uh our
we're we're niched pretty well like I
think we're probably the biggest in our
Niche um it's a smaller group meaning
like there's maybe 2,000 doctors that do
neuropathy
specifically um so and we have 160 of
them so it's not we're still there's
still huge potential for us to I think
we get 300 or 500 or th000 maybe I don't
know what's the Ang go for you
um I'm I'm just cash okay yeah yeah no I
I asked because it's like is it to build
it to sell it is it to have yeah I mean
I think selling would be cool it has to
it have to go to different verticals I
mean I'm like I'm way too risky on the
checklist oh not necessarily I mean cuz
the thing is is like the the ultimate
version of the model that you have is
like you've got 160 out of like 2,000
neuropathy clinics right so you've got
like pretty decent you know you got
whatever that is 8% um of that like
pseudo of like niche of a niche of a in
Market but those guys make how much
these these guys make a year like um uh
between a million and 5 million right
and so this is where this gets like way
more interesting in my opinion so it's
like you've got 320 million year I'm
just using an average right per year
that you're driving in revenue and it's
like man I'm making five I'm like this
sucks right of
that you're like how can I get more of
that um and so
the thing is is like I think the the
ultimate version for like the the quote
info and agency space that I know those
are different things but fundamentally
they serve Niche Niche avatars that are
B2B um the ultimate version of those
businesses is
rollups of the the customers you serve
because if you think about what like a
rollup does I don't how familiar you are
with it but like you get everyone on the
same marketing you get everyone on the
same price points you get everyone on
the same packages you get basically you
consolidate what everyone's operations
are and that's what the majority of
super Niche agencies and kind of in info
Consulting whatever you want to call it
do with businesses so they do all the
heavy work of integration for what a
rollup would do and then they just say
like okay I'll stop there I just won't
like actually push it over the edge and
monetize the whole thing um and so like
most of the Physicians that I know hate
being Physicians they do it purely to
make money and want to be out of it as
soon as possible and so like selling
them on the idea that like okay your
practice does you whatever 2 and a half
million a year of Topline and whatever 1
million in profit uh that's awesome and
then you have your you know taxes that
you're taking home 600k year after that
like that's great but what if and on
your own this thing could maybe sell for
I don't know 3 million bucks maybe like
maybe if you're really really you know
we're being really generous but if you
were part of a group of Physicians that
were a neuropathy you know thing
Nationwide uh we could probably sell for
like your thing could probably sell for
10 million and so all I'm asking for is
a you know 20 to 30% slice of that but
times
160 and so obviously of the 160 you
wouldn't do with all of them I mean if
you did that would be a monster deal but
like if you could get like 10 or 20 of
them to roll together because they all
probably do have enough like enough
profit together to be meaningful so it's
like if you get the roll up to be like1
to $20 million in terms of profit that
would be a meaningful exit that would be
probably like a 100 to $200 million exit
and you have 20 to 30% of that but then
after that point you're now the guy who
did that and so then your whole
reputation changes your Dynamic changes
around pricing you're a long-term stick
all of that kind of stuff changes
because it's like oh I'm the guy that
can get you to hear and that's also the
like get rich know if you don't have to
do this again which is a much more
compelling offer can I ask you a side
question you guys uh
when you switch to licensing so I
remember I know o OG flying around and
then more less OG they were flying
around for you and then more recent them
doing it for for themselves right and I
gave them the ads that we test yeah
right so the the transition for you from
doing it for them to doing it to then
doing it themselves and you being a
coach does that I would never use that
word but yeah yeah does that work do you
think that that looking back would you
would you have done it that exact same
way would you have switched to the
licensing model and like and is that
what you're calling licensing joke I
mean because like we had ads that we
would test every month and then we would
just let everybody else use them and
tons of people tried to use them that
weren't are because they would copy the
gyms that we had ads and they'd like I'd
have ads gyms using my face to run ads
for their gym it happened all the time
so um would I do the model we had again
yes the reason that we didn't do done
for you was two things one is or like
the reason do it yourself for your
avatar doesn't work is that they make
too much money yeah a gym owner the
value of learning the skill exceeds
their current skill it makes more sense
for somebody who makes $35,000 a year to
learn how to Market and sell than
somebody who makes a million dollar here
to learn how to Market and sell they've
already leveled out of that in terms of
like because they can pay somebody less
than they make to do this for them
whereas the gym owner can't it makes
sense for them to learn that skill
and then from the reason I didn't do a
rollup is because group based service uh
there's zero there's zero market for it
no one wants to buy them if I had been
in a market where people were buying for
like for sure I would be I would that
would have been the model I would do
beautiful yeah out of respect for I'm
going to rock and roll does that make
sense sweet yeah so we do permanent
holiday lighting that's R off a
Smartphone um on homes and businesses um
my question I guess would be or I guess
our constraints we have no Revenue
retention um and so we've dabbled with
you know maybe doing like a a
maintenance plan you know where we
upsell people things like that um or you
know having paid subscriptions in our
app but so who's your customer most of
the time uh it's kind of a it's a
healthy split between like elderly and
then like people want to keep up with
the
Jes okay and so the light so tell me
more about like tell me more a little
bit more about the product is have a
better understanding of it yeah so
basically um we install an aluminum
track system into their existing soft
and it's got LEDs and so you can do any
holiday game day accent lighting it's
all right that is that like the Philips
hu type type deal I don't want to like
oversimplify what you're saying I just
want to make sure I understand it it's
kind of like that it's much bigger
cooler what's the average ticket uh
about 5,000 okay how do you get
customers um through Facebook and I
guess met ads but ads you didn't paid
ads in your local yeah okay got it how
many locations just one okay one
location what are margins
um we're about
60% depends on the season um so you make
you make a million bucks you keep 600 no
well we checked about 51 okay great
you're doing half awesome what's
CAC um 300 300 bucks for 5,000 LTV
that's great okay so um so a couple
things so if you want to get Revenue
retention um you want to measure how
long you've been in business so I've
been with the company for a year okay
about two years first year was just you
know vetting products out and stuff got
it but do you own it yeah okay got it
okay you said been with the company so I
was like I don't know what that means
I've been with the acquisition. comom as
well
um um okay so uh so again we're thinking
about this from a revenue retention
perspective um one is is there so you
install this thing for the lighting um
what else do those people want like
is there anything else you can add on
top of it because like you have to
Keeping Up With the Jones I'm sure that
during certain Seasons they want to do
other razzled Dazzle things and so like
you can you can assemble and then
disassemble things multiple times a year
uh for seasons for Super Bowls for
things like that I don't know if that's
too different from the type of lighting
that you currently do but like it's not
too different now I get people asking
all the time if we'll do their trees or
if we'll do you know other stuff that's
not permanent yeah so I would see the
impermanent lighting as like you run two
to three seasonal campaigns a year so
I'll bet you Easter would be one if
you're in Utah I'm sure that'll be big
Christmas will obviously be big in Utah
um and then you know pick your third
date maybe maybe Halloween's not as big
in Utah um I don't know I'm just I'm
just messing around um but even if you
had you know one or two cracks at the
Apple um cracks at the Apple whatever
bites of the Apple uh every year on top
of that that keeps you top of mind and
then like when you go there you're like
hey we also do it like we'll do standard
double check is everything working okay
with the lights it gives you UPS
opportunities but you still like
generate other revenue and then when
they want to replace it's like hey did I
tell you about the new lights cuz these
ones are old now the new ones are oh my
God let me tell you let me show this
thing on my phone I did for your
neighbor Susan down the road hers looks
sick didn't know if you're interested in
that um so it's like those become UPS
opportunities and instead of saying like
it's um recurring it becomes reoccurring
so it's slightly different so like
Coca-Cola has no recurring basically no
recurring members uh member like
memberships but we buy Coca-Cola
products all the time so we have
reoccurring it's reliable Revenue it's
just not on a membership or a
subscription and so basically all you'd
have to demonstrate to make the the the
company a lot more valuable is Simply
Having the data to track that we sell a
customer for lights and we sell one out
of two another thing every year whether
that's an
upgrade a a maintenance fix or it's
lights that we do for Seasons like if we
can just show that half the people
continue to buy something from US every
year that's still
makes it a very valuable business does
that make sense that would be it so my
name is Cameron uh we do Residential
real estate flipping in the state of
Missouri uh we did 15 million Revenue
last year for
3.7 um gross before overhead so 2.5
after you take into account our team 15
meaning like the how much the houses
were when you sold them and then the
three we sold $15 million yeah it was
like house sale price the profit on each
project was 3.7 which is it helps us
tell how well we're doing on the
projects and then you take out our team
and you end up with 2.5 like evida I
guess sure um I was trying to think of
the constraint all all week you know uh
zero Revenue retention got highlighted
in the in the thing but for us I think
it's going to be that I would we've kind
of captured the market we can capture
which for what we do is a driving radius
like we've I would say dominated Within
4 hours of where we're at which is like
you drive 4 hours to a house to evaluate
it and 4 hours back your day is gone um
so we're kind of at a push or pivot
moment of like do
we we do no advertising it's 95%
foreclosures and then like a few word of
mouth so do we pivot would you say
to the rest of Missouri like almost
franchise out like get four little like
find other big cities and and try to get
the rest of Missouri there's probably
like four quadrants or would you go go
into marketing cuz I know I mean doing
95% foreclosures it's like we don't
control our income of properties
whatsoever and we kind of have like that
that one funnel and like if we're clo
like if the economy gets good then you
have no deal flow kind of exactly and
constant through Co foreclosing was
literally illegal in Missouri and we
made 2.7 that year so somehow we made it
happen like you said it's just a lot
freaking harder but there's ways um so I
don't know if it's a push or a pivot I
would say that's our main con there's
things we can improve on but that's like
the one that keeps us up at night right
now let me just say what's the
goal we have a mission statement and
it's to uh make sure that all houses
within our reach are at their highest
and best value because we don't see a
house falling off the market as a good
thing that just makes other real estate
more expensive um I I know the goal is
not necessarily to ever sell so it would
probably be to expand I guess okay so
so you know path one is you just go to
another city and I wouldn't necessarily
call it franchising you just expand it's
just like opening another lighting thing
like that's you just that's just the
normal way of things like if you just
get better and better at it you open
another location um I see that as
another another set of skills for you
which I think will be valuable um and
you could and this time like if it's
basically there's no point I mean you
could go in Missouri but you could also
do any other Market that you'd want
because if you're if you're going past 4
hours of driving now you're in like
flying range in which case pick the
right City you know like pick whatever
City you want to go to um you'll also go
into a city that's going to probably
have competitors you know what I mean
which I see is a good thing um because
it means like the more competitors there
are the more of a market there is um as
long as you're you know number one then
more for you um and so that's that's
high I that's at least my perceptive
perception like whenever people like oh
there's a ton of competition in my
market I'm like that's awesome it means
there's tons of buyers
um and so just side note there but um
cuz the alternative of this is like
literally changing the entirety of your
business exactly which I I would I would
like you're doing well with it how long
you been doing this uh I've been doing
it for eight years yeah dude you've
already paid down like all the ignorance
Deb so like you're at this point you're
like you're like here on your curve like
you're like right here and so it's like
well don't don't jump back down to like
here again right don't go there um like
there's an ultimate version of this and
so what's the who's the biggest uh
wholesaler in the nation the biggest
Wholesale in the nation uh is it We Buy
Ugly Houses probably I mean there's a
lot of me okay so what do they do that
you don't
do um a lot of advertising a ton of
advertising pay pay for click uh mailers
is huge Billboards we do none of that so
I'll
bet that there's still way more deals
even probably even Within your current
market I think so and so I would
probably if I were you so either either
you have to replicate what you're
currently doing in a new market but you
have some of the risks that you've
already brought up which is like you're
all inbound based on foreclosures you
have some of these other things you're
not like the income is not necessarily
reliable um I would definitely learn the
advertising stuff for your own business
cuz like whenever there's an ultimate
version of the business that I'm
currently in it's like they already did
it and so now all I have to do is do it
better than them and whoever bu that
business is already gone probably and so
it's just a bunch of Suits who don't
know how this business works and so it's
just right for us to just murder them
I'm just being I'm just being super
honest like this is how I see it um and
so I think I would just like go 100% try
and pants them um and do PBC like and
like also do some of the stuff they're
probably not doing well they probably
aren't doing social well they probably
aren't running like not as well as they
could obviously their Billboards I know
the Billboards that they run um and but
I'll bet you they've got great sales
training and I'll bet you've got they've
got Great Floors of people and kind of
infrastructure in place and so I would
look at that I would look at their
overarching model as well because I'll
bet you they get a piece on the back end
as well like because they probably
vertically integrated as much as they
possibly could um within the business
that that they actually make more on
every deal than you do so they can spend
more on every deal like they can pay
more like so they have they have ways to
beat other people in all these different
markets cuz they're National right
exactly and so step one would be start
advertising more because then they'll
just immediately make more within your
current market like that would just that
might double your business if you just
did that um and then number two is I
would analyze the living hell out of
them like that's what I would do and
then think about like okay this is this
is the future version of my business one
can I replicate it two is there anything
I can do to make it better 100% I
definitely wouldn't change my business
for sure I think that I think your
advice is dead on it's just what I'm
afraid to do cuz I don't know how to do
it it's like I'll just go do in
different cities but I guess I got to
learn new things darn
right yeah maybe we can help up Alex um
so I'm Joel I have a CPA firm uh based
out of Baker School California but
during Co we went virtual so now we
serve all 50
states um I have a lot of constraints uh
but I think you know my questions would
be you know how do you prioritize what's
revenue revenue is last year was 2.5
this year is probably going to be about
three awesome uh margins last year
900,000 this year net was was the part
going to be about
1.1 um awesome I don't know that's good
but I mean you're running 30% margins on
a on a I mean yeah sou expensive labor
um so I mean I guess my question is yeah
but it's a super reliable business it's
a viable business like accounting firms
get rolled up left and right there's
tons of buyer activity there like it's
very people don't turn out of their
accounts I mean it's like
it's it's very sticky there's High LTV
the issue with accounting is most of the
times um there's no one in there who
knows how to Market and sell that's
usually the issue with accounting
accounting businesses it's like all word
of mouth and no one knows how to like
Market yeah and then the other issue is
is getting good accountants because
there's so much Demand right for decent
accountants and so but like the
accounting firms that I know of like all
have like anybody who comes here with
accounting firm almost always makes
money they're all doing well um so
there's big demand yeah for sure so
what's the issue um I guess one would be
operations um just making sure our
clients are satisfied like we have a
short period of time to do all of our
work mostly during tax season right so
we get clients have certain expectations
getting their tax returns down and we at
capacity but then you know obviously
they don't want to pay a premium
sometimes so I think we need to improve
our sales process to make sure that we
can charge a premium to give them that
value that they're expecting so do you
mostly have one time a year customers or
no it's usually we charge quarterly okay
uh for quity tax planning uhhuh is it
more businesses or more individuals
businesses oh great okay well that's I
mean even better yeah so yeah our I mean
our minimum fee right now is 1950 a
quarter okay uh what's your annual stick
annual stick what do you mean by that uh
what's your Revenue turn annually it's
not as good as I like it to be i'
probably say we keep have you 70% okay
you probably want yeah you want to get
over 80 I mean for for accounting firms
like you probably can do a little better
yeah so I think it has to do with just
also making sure the clients see the
value because after we give them like
certain Tax Strategies they're kind of
like oh I kind of learned this now I can
find a cheaper accountant sometimes so
even though there is that stickiness you
know they especially some business
owners will be like oh I kind of sell
the value what you guys did last I I I'm
not sure I buy that I think what someone
says on the exit versus why they
actually can aren't necessarily the same
thing um cuz like I I already got the
value is like literally what everyone
says when they want to leave anything
and it's just cuz like they just want to
leave um because I mean I what you want
is I mean fundamentally from an
accountant you want somebody who will
get you to pay as few tax as humanly
possible and keep you out of jail and
that's pretty much that's pretty much
the that's the task yeah and um make it
as little work for you as humanly
possible for that to occur right and so
I mean just me having been a consumer of
many different accounting firms and
accountants and employees who were you
know who did that stuff for us um I
don't I don't buy the like we taught
them the two or three tricks yeah um
also I bet you a bunch of your business
owners aren't even like close to it some
of them are bigger and like aren't
they're just like yeah just pay the bill
I don't I don't really care just make
sure it's right so I would bet that you
probably have bad
onboarding okay so basically the expect
basically the Delta between what they're
sold and then what their experience is
in the first handful of days and weeks
going into it and then the communication
Cadence between touch bases they
probably see limited value there and so
I think um I would give you the same
kind of like if I were to like buy 100%
of your business tomorrow I would audit
the sales process to handoff like I
would bet you there's a massive amount
of opportunity there in terms of like
how can we take more notes on every
customer because the I get pissed off if
I feel like I'm talking to somebody they
don't know much about my business and
I'm paying them $8,000 year my taxes
right immediately I'd be like oh yeah
[__] you like I know you can't be
looking at like I can just do back of
napkin brain math of like if you barely
know who I am you definitely don't know
how to save me money on my taxes right
and we do have an onboarding process but
there might be a disconnect between the
sales well we already know there's a
disconnect cuz you said there
was so this is me this is me trying to
help so I would go really deep on the
onboarding process which is like how can
I really tighten this up both in terms
of the personalization of the
communication and how can I speed up the
number of times you communicate with
them because you want frequent
communication as long as like it's
pushed so it's not me asking for [__]
you know CU then I [__] hate you
right like if you ask me for St but if
it's like hey uh just letting you know
we ran this today this thing is moving
forward everything's good nothing for
you just keep you in the loop and then
two days later hey we also ran this
thing um XYZ is done and it's moving
forward to the next step I'd be like oh
[__] they're doing stuff and so like I
tell this to everybody but no one does
it and so this is me telling you and
hopefully you will do it but like if you
do a hundred things you want to let them
know every time you're doing one of
those things on their behalf and they're
like dude these guys are working for me
all the time like this guy works his ass
off and then someone else is like well
they're doing it for 8,000 I'll do it
for six and they're you're like oh no
these guys work their asses off for me
like I'm sure I'm safe like no one
actually knows it's kind of like when
the guy comes to your your house like
especially the nicer the neighborhood
you live in you know this like he's like
think I could do the lighting for 10
grand I'm like dud you think I got this
house because I let people rip me off I
was like give me the r price and then
it's like all right I can do it for four
and you're like great you know or
whatever and so the thing is is like no
one really knows they just they just gut
call on the fact that like my
communication with this company's been
crappy the expectations are poor and so
if this is my external experience I'll
bet you they're not crossing their tees
and dotting their eyes on my
taxes that would be my guess right and
so I think if you get all of the other
stuff tight they will just get yes that
your internal stuff's as tight which I
hope it is um and I'll bet you that'll
keep the stick honestly and of course
accountants don't know how to deal with
customers so I bet you probably need to
train them again on that communication
Cadence so it's basically way more
personalized way more frequent uh
communication and then probably very
tight training on how to have touchpoint
calls with the customers right that
makes or clients whatever for
sure that' be like the number one thing
I would do I wouldn't even do anything
else I mean do you think it's scalable
too cuz I mean my biggest yes accounting
firms are scalable ey KPMG like yes
they're scalable price yeah PWC think
those are publicly trading accounting
firms yes they're scalable what do you
think about like one of the thing you
mentioned I think yes yesterday was like
you
know the size of the brain the biggest
brain is as big as you know so I I'm
starting to now hire people that are
smarter than me in other areas like uh
but when it comes to accounting I'm
still like the smartest person in the
room yeah there's smarter accountants I
don't say this a slight I just say like
look at the guys that keep like they're
some smart dudes yeah I mean I kind of
want to hire like cuz I'm more of a CEO
than I am a tax nerd yeah so I rather
hire like yeah go get a tax nerd yeah
yeah you go recruit somebody from one of
those companies who's like I need
somebody who worked at Enron who wasn't
a bad guy you know what I mean and
figure out like who can do like the real
the crazy stuff who knows the tax like
who reads tax law for fun yeah like
that's who you need cuz there are dudes
who do who are like oh curled up on like
I know a buddy of mine who literally
goes to the pool with the tax law his
kids are in the pool and he's reading it
and I'm like what is wrong with you he's
like I just love this stuff and I was
like I'm glad someone does you know like
and he's like look at this hole he's
like oh I'm going to crush this one and
he's like he's like this is legal it's
like he just like loves it's like for
him is like treasure hunting so like you
need somebody who's like that and if
that's not you then you should have
somebody who is that way yeah for sure
so yes I agree and I think you should do
that I would say step one though fix all
the outside stuff step two go get that
guy cuz that stuff will make you more
money today with what you already have
than do the other thing right so newer
SAS company we help inbound sales teams
improve their or eliminate no shows
improve their sales off and self
efficiency um I really think the most
helpful thing for me would be just you
running
through
um really the major learning lessons you
had from Allen in terms of red plaque my
my background is high tiet education and
for that whole stay so I think I'm kind
of coming into it you know do you have
his technical co-founder I do okay how
good is he I spent 18 months fighting so
okay he's pretty good well that could
mean that it just took you really long
to find somebody who's bad so
like um two years from now you're like I
should have know yeah um so it really
comes down to like has this person built
a solare company before yeah Okay cool
so fundamentally like the entire game's
different than the High tiet game right
like it's all about Revenue retention
it's all about word of mouth it's it's a
product business there's actually a
podcast I just made I don't even know
when it's coming out about this but like
what business are you really in and so
like when I got into Allen I thought I
was in the marketing and sales business
because that was the business that I
came from but you're actually in the
product business so it has to be it has
to be basically like taking to its
natural extreme if people don't stick
with it it doesn't
matter so basically marketing and doing
everything else like it's irrelevant
right and so like unless that's right
nothing else matters basically and so
Marketing sales in the front end
literally only serves the purpose of
making the product better until there's
a point where it has what I would
consider passive growth where it grows
on its own and then you gas the living
hell out of it and then that's what
makes gazillion doll companies like if
you want low turn you either have to go
up market and find the people who don't
turn out or you have to help create the
people who don't
turn so like the Shopify and the Spotify
a lot of IFI here um there's going to be
there's cohort churn which you're
probably familiar with if you're
co-founders in this so like you're going
to have periods of time where it's like
okay the first six months we turn out
[__] 80% of our customers but the 20%
after that point our retention curve is
flat and so you just have to figure out
once you get to that data cohort you're
like okay what do these people look like
and then you readjust the messaging
readjust uh the marketing so you can get
more and more of those people so you get
a bigger and bigger slice of them and
funly that Loop is what will you more or
less focus on um and then I think about
it from when I'm trying to reverse
engineer the customer Avatar it's like
you have psychographics like what do
they believe you have demographics what
do they look like where are they from
you have Geographics or where where are
they um and then you have kind of
activities which is like what did they
do so if I'm trying to reverse engineer
what the people who spend the most money
with me look like I look through those
those lenses who are they where are they
from what do they believe what do they
do and then I try and say in my ads hey
I'm looking for people who believe these
things I look in the places that they're
at um and then once they're in I try and
get them to do the same things that the
people who were successful who look like
them who talk like them who believe like
them did in order to be successful so
like in the beginning you just do a ton
of marketing to get Traction in the door
and that's literally just so you can
like see if people like it see where
they're turning out see get basically
you just want feedback and then once you
find what people are liking what they're
successful with obviously iterate from a
product perspective on the road map to
do more of the stuff that core in terms
of value but then the marketing side it
Loops back and then that's what informs
who you're picking on the front end who
you're marketing to right so you being
much more specific form and totally call
the people to STI yes yes and the hard
part is that your sales team won't want
to do it and you will not want to say no
to money yeah but I I understand a
company persp for the
Mak cool but that's I mean fundamentally
like if you good Vista um I I became
friendly acquaintances with their their
head of pricing and packaging and he was
just like if you don't do you know vist
is so they're out of aost in100 billion
dollar private Equity they're they'd be
like the fifth biggest company like
whatever they're massive um and they
only they're private Equity they and
they buy software companies and they
triple them in in in three years which
is their goal and they flip them and so
um the founder I can't remember his name
now I feel bad um is uh anyways rich
I'll just put that way um point being I
was talking to the head of packaging and
he said you want to know our whole
secret and I was like what man he's like
we just know our our quired companies's
customers better than they do I was like
what do you mean he's like so we go into
the data room and we look at all the
customers they have and we look at what
channels they came from we look at who
they are how they act all that stuff
he's like then we turn off all the
marketing that's not those customers and
we crank the living hell out of the
stuff that is that and we do nothing
else on the company
Tres obviously it's more than that but
fun like big picture strategy that's
what they do we get more the people who
spend the most
money but people just aren't disciplined
and that's why people just stay poor
because then they they try and serve too
many people too many different avatars
they can't say not of money today so
they don't get the big money
tomorrow cool appreciate than you hi I'm
AR Alex uh DTC fishion brand Commerce
Indonesia from Indonesia doing $10
million a year addit that $3 million
been doing this nine years awesome
uh thanks for making it out thank you
how do I know when to expand new product
line what are you selling now what do
you sell now t-shirt shirt pants Jeans
jacket but mostly man were is it white
is it white label or a brand say it
again is it your brand or is it my BR
your brand I manufactur I I'm not
manufacturer I suck con to the other
Factory in India and then I only own the
office and the warehouse is it custom
do you design it or you just slap your
leg you design it knock off no that's
fine I mean like hey I'm I'm I'm not I
don't dud competition's competition um
as long as you're not hacking their
databases or anything like that's I mean
that's the nature of the retail business
I understand it um okay
so the question that you have is how do
how do you scale it or basically how do
you add more to expand new product line
let's say Woman's let's say sports o
because I'm doing casual only let's say
formal um I don't think at 10 million
you need to like like you could do so
much more even within that within that
that demographic like if you're just
mostly men's wear like there's tons of
massive Men's Wear companies can I add
to that yeah add yeah I'm thinking about
that also because I haven't achieved 200
or $300 million yet isn't it isn't it
will make my brand to man were letter in
life so I'm not building enough
Foundation to capture the woman's
letter in$ 300 $500 million
mon 500 million a month that would be a
lot
um it's a tough call man I'll be honest
with you because like on one level I
mean if you're like I want to build the
next Nike then yeah you're going to have
to sell to everybody but even Nike
doesn't sell
suits right just like like there's so
like there's so many people who buy so
much clothing um and I mean I think so
right now I think you're a little bit of
of like a brand identity spot like you
obviously know how to convert I'm
guessing are you running ads yeah right
so you know like you know you know that
game and you run really good margins I'm
sure on the on the products based on and
and you can you know how to run run ads
at scale and
so what I think right now is you have to
figure out who who you want to become as
a brand so if you like Men's Wear then
like you can be I think you can build a
massive Men's Work company just being
real I mean just being really
transparent with you like you can U
build a massive vsware company also like
Lou Lemon doesn't do I guess they have
like pants that are nice but like
they're all sportswar so like I mean
lemon's a terrible example now because
they're just gone to crap but like um
like if you look at these I like like I
just as a framework for everybody like I
look at what's the biggest version of
the business that's currently here like
what did they do to get there what does
their business model look like and then
how many steps between where I'm at and
where they are do I need to take and
like what lessons or what what skills am
I deficient in and then it's like okay
well then those skill deficiencies
become the opportunity like
fundamentally that's it and what their
brand looks like and how they monetize
like are they vertically integrated or
like if I was getting into the into the
energy drink business I'd be like okay
well Red Bull has outsourced literally
everything besides marketing so I guess
that might be the most important thing
for a consumer packaged good that's you
know rtds ready to drink and
distribution so it's like they have
massive brand plays massive distribution
you know they have their recipe
underlock and key and everything else is
is so like basically I would look at the
brand like is there a brand that you
want to emulate uh basically I'm I'm
what problem are with uh am I solving is
just a billion dollar exit building
consulting firm and then that is a lid
magnet to PE build media and then
control the Indonesia okay so my goal
just I'll a billion liquid cast Okay
well let's take so right now we sell
clothes so let's a couple I get it I
appreciate that so I want to I want to
increase the like that you get there so
I think like you can make this thing
very valuable without doing all of the
other stuff that you were talking about
so I think like you absolutely can do
this and then think okay why can't I get
this to $100 million a year selling
men's Weare like why can't I and I think
that way then it's like okay is there a
is there a brand person who can endorse
this like if you look at the big retail
Brands they have big
endorsers who stand next to the product
that increases conversion increases the
premium you can charge and so instead of
knocking off Zara you just become a
brand and I think honestly I think
that's the gap for you like you're
obviously very good at the Arbitrage of
media to to clicks and whatnot but like
I think you need to go from that to
building a brand and then that's what
will make it sellable so this is what I
like that's the tldr of our conversation
is that's what makes your thing valuable
is you need to build a brand